I have never met Amanda Lori I've only
read the stories
your name will be legendary
it's a world more peaceful since a
revolution it is a shame that your
people suffered but bounty hunting is a
complicated professor
they said you were coming
they said you were the best in the
Parcak would you agree
[Music]
when DeLorean
look outside
waiting for you
yeah good
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
a brand new trailer for Star Wars the
Mandalorian we have the debut of Ming
nas character and we found out who Nick
Nolte is voicing on the series so we'll
break it all down there's even some
Easter eggs for Star Wars Episode one
The Phantom Menace Episode two the Clone
Wars in Episode one of the Mandalorian
series which is premiering next week I
will be doing Easter Egg videos and
breakdowns of all the episodes so be
sure to subscribe if you're brand new to
my channel and I will do giveaways for
Disney Plus or some Star Wars themed
giveaway based on what you guys want all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about who the Mandalorian is on the
video just going through the footage and
then I'll talk about the Easter eggs
behind me nas character Nick Nolte's
character in all the Star Wars Phantom
Menace and Clone Wars Easter eggs you
start with the voiceover from Nick
Nolte's character he's voicing an egg
not bounty hunter here named quill I
don't know how they're going to
pronounce his name on the series but
this is how it's spelled he seems like
he partners up with the Mandalorian for
at least some of the episodes I don't
know if he's gonna be around for the
entire series but Nick Nolte is pretty
big actor you wouldn't cast him if he
wasn't going to be playing a pretty big
character his voice over speech and Ming
nas quote and the rest of the trailer
just meant to hype up the legends of the
Mandalorians themselves he's called the
Mandalorian your name will be legendary
but his eggnog character says I've never
seen a Mandalorian before I've only
heard about them while this is happening
we see new footage of an r5 droid in
this town where a lot of the footage has
been taking place most of the series is
obviously paying reference to the
original trilogy but their Easter eggs
from all across the series like I say
going back to the prequels as well the
r5 droid reference is mostly for episode
4 when the Jawas tried to sell it - oh
and large but instead because of Luke's
insistence and c-3po s help they wind up
buying r2d2 instead no buy that droid
he's way better and he has all these
secret plans there's new footage of him
walking into the cantina with a trans
dosha bounty hunter like Bosque him
beating the crap out of the quarren
bounty hunter in the bar as Nick Nolte's
voiceover continues new footage of him
riding the Dewback like the
stormtroopers from Star Wars Episode
four the new footage of scout troopers
riding speeder bikes across the plains
of whatever this main planet they're on
in the
they still have not revealed which
planet they're on there's new scenes of
IG 11 voiced by Taika Waititi having
another gunslinger stand off new footage
of the Mandalorian in his ship the razor
crest entering hyperspace new footage of
him in Gina Carano scare achter Keira
dune diving away from some bomb
explosion in their camp cue Wilhelm
scream
[Music]
then a really cool montage of him
armoring up before heading out and
noticed that he's wearing a lot of the
low file looking beaten up armor in this
part of the trailer whereas in some of
the other trailer footage he's wearing
the really shiny upgraded looking best
scar armor best car metal is just a
really special metal that Mandalorians
used to make their armor the really cool
property that it has in addition to just
being really strong is that it's also
light saber resistant which is why it's
come in so handy during the Old Republic
era when Jedi were still a really big
presence in the galaxy we don't know if
they're gonna be in a Jedi showing up
during this series because it takes
place after Return of the Jedi so really
Luke Skywalker is one of the few Jedi
that we know about but there are a lot
of other rogue Force sensitive people or
people who used to be Jedi that are
probably somewhere in the Outer Rim
territories that might pop up I know a
lot of you have also asked about the
dark saber where's the dark saber as of
right now because the last time we saw
it was during Star Wars rebels and that
takes place right before Star Wars
Episode four a new hope I'll talk about
that in a second - then he gets a new
footage of him using his wrist gauntlet
blaster just like Boba Fett to take down
whatever this giant animal bounty is the
series is meant to be very space Western
so this is kind of like him cattle
wrangling a giant space ball he's trying
to take down but then you get the new
footage of Ming nas character talking
about him being legendary but if you've
been watching Ming da for the last
couple of years on agents of shield as
you would expect she's playing a bounty
hunter and a mercenary named finish and
they said the inspiration for her name
came from fennec foxes and they tried to
come up with a very fennec fox inspired
hairstyle so even though it's pulled
back because she typically wears a
helmet a lot of the time there's a
special braise that you can't really see
in these trailers designed to look like
fennecs foxes the interview that she
gave about her character just says she's
tricky and yet she's able to maneuver
and survive and be stealthy so very
graceful and agile I just love the whole
image of the name she doesn't say
whether she's a good character or a bad
character but the whole idea of doing a
series based around banning hunters that
is going to explore that area of grey
morality within the Star Wars universe
the other really cool thing is all the
Star Wars Episode one in Episode two
Clone Wars and Phantom Menace stuff
they've actually clarified in this other
trailer footage there are scenes where
you see this young boy in the middle of
this giant war in the
middle of town those are scenes from the
Mandalorian episode 1 as well as Star
Wars Episode one Phantom Menace in
Episode two the Clone Wars
those scenes of the young child are
actually flashbacks that the Mandalorian
character is experiencing showing his
childhood in the Outer Rim territories
during the Galactic Civil War with the
separatists in the Old Republic that's
why you're seeing these giant battle
droids from the prequels marching into
the town square firing on everyone in
the separatist droid gunship flying
overhead just to let you know that this
is a flashback and it's taking place
during the prequel era Dave Filoni and
Jon Favreau have said that they included
Easter eggs from all over the Star Wars
timeline in the series all the movies
all the TV shows even reek and Isaac
some of the Star Wars Expanded Universe
material the Disney kind of got rid of
when they bought Star Wars there been a
couple big things from the expanded
universe that have come back Thrawn is
one of the biggest things they did that
on rebels I believe this is the first
time in this Mandalorian series that
we've seen footage that takes place
during the prequel era though so I'm
assuming that we'll see more flashbacks
for his character they sort of informed
why he is the way he is where he came
from without completely telling us
everything about his backstory I think
the whole idea is that he's supposed to
be a bit mysterious but we might learn
more about his tie to the Mandalorian
culture what his clan was I'll explain
more about what happened to the
Mandalorians after the Clone Wars in a
second because you don't really
encounter them a lot during the original
trilogy and this obviously takes place
right after Return of the Jedi so
there's a big question about what's
going on with the Mandalorians in the
galaxy at this point but Dave Filoni has
also been hyping up Clone Wars animated
series characters showing up in the
live-action Disney Plus series so it
makes sense they would include scenes
from that era of the Star Wars timeline
during the first couple of episodes the
last really big Mandalorian centric
story that we got was on Star Wars
rebels taking place right before Star
Wars Episode four a new hope and during
that they had just gone through a big
Mandalorian Civil War
Sabine one of the main characters from
the rebels team helped reunite all the
Mandalorian clans they picked a new
leader named lady Bo Catan who was given
the dark saber which is sort of the mark
of leadership for the Mandalorian people
the remaining Mandalorian clans as of
Star Wars Episode four were the villas
the Ren's the crazes the
the elders and a journeyman protector
Rao so they were still a relatively
small collection of different
Mandalorian clans all disparately living
all over the place there was no central
location they lost their home planet
Mandalore to Imperial occupation and
they were trying to get that back it was
implied they fell on harder times again
during the rise of the Empire then you
have the war with the rebellion and even
though there aren't a lot of answers
about what's going on with them around
that period it's also implied that
they're basically a fractured culture of
clans living all over the Outer Rim
territories so there's still kind of a
scattered people but the dark saber
still exists they could still use it on
the TV show if you're unfamiliar with
the legend of the dark saber it actually
belonged to the very first Mandalorian
in Star Wars history that was inducted
into the Jedi Order thousands of years
ago after he passed away house vizla at
the time snuck in to the Jedi Temple
liberated it and then used that
lightsaber to unify the Mandalorian
people and strike down as they would say
anyone who'd oppose them over the next
hundreds and hundreds of years the dark
saber would be passed down from one
leader to the next of the Mandalorian
culture as a sort of symbol of their
right to rule so if it wasn't clear even
though the dark saber blade looks a
little bit different from traditional
lightsaber blades it really is just a
regular light saber that's thousands of
years old but what's happening next week
is Disney Plus is gonna release the
Mandalorian episode one on Tuesday I'll
post my video after it airs but all the
other episodes are gonna air on these
days so typically it's gonna be a Friday
show so episode two will be released a
couple days after episode one let me
know in the comments if there's any big
questions you have about the series or
any big requests that you want to make
for the bonus videos that I do Rick and
Morty's season four is also starting
next week so there's gonna be a lot of
really cool stuff coming up while you
wait for everything click here for the
brand-new Rick and Morty season 4
trailer and click here for that brand
new Spider Man into the spider-verse 2
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight